hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - now
we're looking for a bell which belongs
to the little girl who's brother of the
male twins I don't know where this Bell
is and I don't know where I need to go
but I do need to explore I don't think
it's going to be in the upper area but
this presents a problem because I've
kind of explored all of the lower area
already while I was wandering around
like an idiot now this kind of is a
problem because I need to remove my bias
of where I've been in the past because
of a think about that before it's kind
of gotten me in trouble because I was
looking for that well and I was biased
because I was under the assumption that
I had already been where it wanted me to
go so there's a few places that I want
to explore first and then I'm gonna
wander around and try to really think
about where in the hell this little girl
could be if I do need to find her again
because I don't really know all in all
I'm looking for a key I'm looking for a
key that has to do with some bells and
other than that I don't really know now
the last timer the Bell was after I beat
her upstairs so I can't have inclined to
go upstairs again because it's not gonna
be anything over here at least fari know
when you're just going here just in case
just to take care of everything and make
sure I could cover all my bases oh man
I've still got the perennial problem
having too much saliva in my mouth it's
a real problem it doesn't I know it
sounds dirty but it's not when I talk a
lot or when I have a lot of water or
something's going on I get a buildup of
excess saliva and it's not good I'm
gonna keep talking about I don't care if
you're uncomfortable this is just the
life I live so anyway okay so I don't
think there's anything here and I don't
think I need to scream about my personal
problems in the ears of everyone
listening here it seems oddly
inappropriate for me to do but hey
that's me that's what I did
okay so there's nothing over there and
then nothing over here okay so now that
I've properly limited to this place I've
wasted just a little bit more time I'm
starting to realize how hot it is in
here and I've been sweating my butt off
trying to play these games in a room
that's extremely hot and I did not turn
on why did you turn around I wasn't even
touching the controls that time let me
just take a breather this game this
episode is off do too much of an
energetic start and I probably should
just find where around where I'm
supposed to go before I started the
episode anyway I had a lot
that I wanted to talk with you about
namely how's your day been have you been
doing how are you doing as a person are
you good because I'm good and I know
that you guys out there good too so I'm
so glad that we're all part of the same
happy family and we're all good together
I'm gonna have such a fun time relaxing
here in fail frame and oh my god what's
that it's a zombie
oh no ain't no zombies here okay I
really don't know where it wants me to
go I'm in the clock Hall which means
that it's gonna take me back up to the
upper floor if I do that which is
entirely possible that I need to go up
to the upper floor so I might as well
just keep like exploring everywhere that
it wants me to go but at the end of the
day I don't know what I'm supposed to be
doing because I kind of missed out on
some clues I know there's got to be a
pellet he's probably very close to where
I was before so it might be my best bet
is to go back in that direction listen
again I don't know I don't know if it
needs me to explore everywhere first I
really don't know I want to know and I
feel bad not knowing but hey that's the
story of my life okay so where does that
door go oh that door doesn't go anywhere
because that doors locked up now where
does that door go does that build grow
anywhere and let me double-check that I
don't know if I been in here or if this
one's locked up if this one is not
locked I feel like this might have been
locked up before and Lissa's is a small
storage room
yeah but small storage area wait wait
yeah hey hey
what the hell
since when is this allowed
well those a bit I was a righty coming
up all the walls oh my god alright then
I don't think there's any other purpose
cities is there what was the point of
that cuz it's a room I was supposed to
find just so I can freak out a little
bit that's awesome
I want more of that I will admit that
this game hasn't really been all that
terrifying to me like I know a lot of
people played it up because that's where
my U is yeah yeah my I'm coming to get
you I know the Bell design lock I'll get
it someday somewhere somehow yeah this
game hasn't been utterly terrifying to
me now I'm holding out because I will
admit the game has gotten progressively
scarier as it goes along but I mean I
wish I kind of wish that there was more
punch to it bail bail bail bail bail
bail bail bail bail god damn it bail
bail hell's going on
I hear the dirt very distinct Oh God
I hear the various - thinks she's
hanging of someone with a bail where's
the bail huh this is the same place wait
a minute no I've been here no no no I
did this I did this
what are you doing then I open the wrong
save how am I really that big of a
dingus what in the world I did this I
did this I did this
Damon I could have gotten one hit in I
guess well alright I'll be right back
because apparently I've loaded up the
wrong st. but no I didn't I opened up
the right save alright whatever I'll be
right back anyway
Oh Stark why is it dark why is it dark
why is it dark why is the pitch black
why is it dark
that didn't happen before what is going
on what is evident
oh god why is it dark okay
this new kid yeah hey huh okay alright
that's really weird oh oh hi okay
alright then what the hell was that it
didn't happen before done yet done in
rings okay so I did that before why did
that happen again
I could I swear I did that before and I
loaded up the same save file late not
the same but you know it I meant I lit
it up the different save beyal
file file file whatever I'm really
really really confused now more than
ever because I thought that I'd done
everything that I needed to do up until
that point but apparently even that was
wrong so I just need to like eliminate
all my assumptions I guess just gotta
keep an open mind and look for a goddamn
bail wherever the hell that goddamn bail
might be but that means that the places
that I just looked might be the place
where I needed to go in the first place
and it's not there anymore damn it
oh I'm just gonna have to cycle back
again again alright so I got to pick a
place to go because otherwise I'm just
gonna keep wandering around in circles
over and over again I'm not gonna get
anywhere I mean I could back go back
over to the entrance again because for
some reason it decided that the first
time I did that it wasn't good enough
and I wasn't able to do it I need
probably need to go back again and
whatever but that's a whole nother story
for another day and I don't have to deal
with that [ __ ] over and over and
over again okay so as far as I know my
current objective is just that I need to
find
ah give me a clue oh hey clue oh my god
it's clue
I want a clue BAM give me a clue give me
a clue Oh
give me a clue wait no no I took a
picture of that you dingus and this is
this is exactly where I was supposed to
go before this is exactly the first
place I went to before and this dingus
Barry whatever give me our picture and
then we'll Amy there you go
all right now that I got that aggression
out of my system hopefully I can carry
on with a level head we all know that's
not gonna happen because Marga Blair is
now 1 for level heads margul R is 1 for
screaming randomly within this case not
randomly because this game is just being
bald um a game is being bull okay
where'd she go where'd she go
where does this Bologna where'd she go
where'd she go oh okay house barely
knows
yeah oh no she's gone whoops not what I
meant to do here beer you buy me well I
see you hey little girl you want y'all
come attack me please attack me
attack me a tank may attack me okay
never mind then
sorry I guess I you just you can't
attack me this is a big baby I'm capable
of attacking anybody you wouldn't harm a
fly how much you try to harm me oh gee
army I may do something me don't make it
dark because I was creepy before oh
hello
do something you can't you can't what
you can't hurt me yeah you damn right
you can't oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh man yeah whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey hey hey hey hey hey
where'd you where'd you go where'd you
go where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go where'd you go as you go let's go
oh where am I for the hell am I now well
they'll they go
oh dammit tomten ah I see
but I'm a can I get a combo can I get
combo double shop BAM - hit come three
hit combo yeah yeah what what did I get
a key come on tell me you got a key give
me that key baby give me the key give me
the key give me the key oh don't tell me
I got to go find her again
Oh goddamn it
well I gotta find her one more time
because Olli the power three or whatever
find her three times killer Vanquisher
spirit three times and then you live a
happy life and whatever whatever
whatever okay so I just got to keep
wandering until she guides me to where
I'm going next
goddamn well I was right I was right to
be I was right to be well little miffed
about all this because obviously it
wasn't my fault
I was under the assumption that I had
already beaten her and I went to the
place where I was supposed to go in the
first place and I didn't even know I was
supposed to go there whose is my random
luck that I went to the blunt place I
was supposed to be but then everyone was
you guys out there were pouring it out
like oh my god why is it a trigger right
now oh my god this game is all broken
he's never gonna be able to believe the
game never again I heard that hello
movie in the closet it okay never mind
something must be oh hey there well
hello there hello hey how'd it go near
Howdy Doody okay never mind then okay is
that the same writing on the wall that I
saw before do I need to go back to hope
there you
hello attack me bring it on I'm ready
for you
I'm ready not gonna fine I'll just take
a picture of you down on the ground I
guess good enough for me
I'll get to you eventually still make it
all dark again because they didn't like
none today oh can I get a Tribble ah it
was right there god damn it ah so close
so close so close but I almost got you
whoa whoa
okay good enough picture for me she's
kind of in my leg there but that's
alright I guess
alright come on where you whoa Tammy Bay
hit me hit me hard
my Hemi penny oh I see how you going
you're scared
so am I not really help hold still whoa
whoa hey hey look at me the other gimme
gimme gimme gimme
I got damnit behind the goddamn door
dammit ah
I'll add that one oh hey are they gonna
take pictures of your winner I can find
you if you're not gonna attack right
away these pictures don't seem to be
doing as much damage I was hoping they
were gonna be doing what hey oh hey what
do you think you're doing they're gonna
get this double but I get this double
pop get oh I was so close that's really
hard to do she's got a lot of help now I
bet I'm gonna finish this off all in
that one little place I'm just gonna
take your tree oh that didn't do
anything
grandi fraud oh I got that one oh yeah
oh well this is a situation
yet China over I'll help you ma'am I
love you Bobby
I'll be in to the Oh got it can with
this baloney ah damn I'll admit this is
the freakiest fight with the turning the
lights out I don't like him I owe
I got a picture I did it can I get a
combo I don't even know where she went
damn it I don't know how I managed to do
this but I'm getting good at this game
oh yeah oh you disappeared oh yeah oh oh
oh
someone's moving whoa okay
yeah oh there and you're gone good final
picture I liked it it's good enough good
enough for me yeah I'm dating I'm doing
a good I can't why are you trying to get
me to do it
of all the people that could possibly do
it I'm definitely not the one to do it
okay the Bell has been tied to the key
with the Crimson cord the girl must have
dropped it I got the Bell key okay red
speckled crystal all right let's take a
listen to that I'm doing so good I'm so
proud of myself I'm humble enough to say
that I'm doing fantastic that's me
no don't think so can't do it yeah I
know I'm not it's okay okay no yeah it's
okay I don't need to help you it's light
bright where I am not that I can see
okay sorry
okay cool all right goodbye thank you
for that time to rescue my sister who's
definitely gonna be there not gonna be a
burden unto me cuz I just need to go up
to the second floor and go over to the
stairway a room that's right into the go
key so I can get there pretty quickly
all right so I go through yeah wait do I
go through healing is this where I go
through oh yeah I go through sha sha
make a pit stop at the CB booth and this
time it'll actually saved correctly
hopefully if it doesn't I'm gonna be
very upset at it cuz it's the son of a
[ __ ] and well they got all I guess out
of [ __ ] ah okay so I just need to go
up the stairs get out of this Japanese
hellhole that I found myself in
wibblewobble up the stairs a little
goodie bitty bit Wibbly Webley Wibbly
wiggly wiggly wiggly where
BAM okay so I go over here for yon away
ignore all the nightmares nor all the
repressed memories Oh what who's there
who's there
Oh who's there oh hey what are you doing
here didn't I take care of you already
contact me Oh
whoops ow is a Miss swing and a Miss
come on give me give me give me give
give give
okay that's one not a veil is not a
fatal frame but give me another gave me
another yeah you looking good
three acabo baby I get a four-hit now
it's gonna be like that I don't know
what the hell you came from anyway oh
you're one of those who stand or typical
ghosts the ones I like I haven't seen
one of you guys so I am getting better
I'm getting a lot better I'm getting
much good or better cooter and I got a
lot of points on that one because I get
a lot of good shots and that's what I am
I'm a cameo obscura Abbotsford maybe I
was supposed to go down that hole coz he
was kind of gardening that way I mean
it's been a while since I just met a
like a straight-up stand up and fight
ghost
you don't seem off course of course I
don't
why would I kids in one place one place
to stay right there does for a little
bit then I'd be able to get on with my
life when we be able to go home why did
we even go here in the first place give
me whatever the hell that is
Itsuki I pray that you read this I can't
stay in this village any longer I told
you I inside that I would come for them
on the day of the ceremony after they
make it out of the village I'll take
care of them don't worry when I get them
out I'll come back for you next no I
won't Rios Omaha cotta
I shouldn't have wrote that out loud in
this diary I'll definitely come get you
no I won't
I did it again Thank You Rio go go go
Ryoko from Tenchi Muyo if we perform the
crimson sacrifice then yah and saya will
not need to go through with the ritual
but if our ritual fails that will be the
only ones left for the next sacrifice I
have to get yah inside out of this
village hor has to stop there has to be
another way I cannot let guy inside
suffer like this the old passageway
under the cure a house Ryan has been
sealed ever since some twins tried to
escape through there long ago the
ceremony master said that they were
killed by came in during their escape
concerned the old the ceremony master
sealed the old tree which enshrines are
remaining although the path is sealed
the passageway still leads out opening
the seal should make it possible to
leave the village
the pinwheel keys that open the seal
have been handed down through the
families of four veiled priests I was
able to find the pinwheel for this
family in the storehouse after passing
through the passageway you only have to
run through the forest to remember to
never look back
will those two have the willpower
necessary okay so I need to go to the
storehouse the diary a small tablet and
crystal Don's ebonic rest flow alright
good fluorite my favorite type of right
through here we can get out of the
village who are you talking to that's
why you shouldn't say things out loud
you dingus
I say how you doing babe
oh so you I don't know what's happening
to me
no matter what happens I forgive you my
am don't leave me
of course I won't leave you behind
oh yeah sure oh I'm looking for you oh
yeah that's what I did yeah of course I
did
oh yeah sure yeah okay
finally I got my good old sister back
now we'll be able to escape through the
storehouse and now I having a company
here to distract the ghost for what the
hell well how do we get out here it's
beginning hurry we need to get all three
okay thanks I don't know how I got here
but okay whatever
I leave for finally out of the house I
guess we pride all the boards off the
door is something okay this doesn't make
any sense but hey whatever we're outside
it saved me a little bit of time and I
don't have to go limping through the
whole house to be able to get where I
need to go uh come along sister mine
baby sis are you the younger sis or the
older one I'm assuming we're twins
cuz that would explain a whole lot okay
so we need to get to the old tree uh I
think I recall there being something
about an old tree over here back in the
beginning area where we were originally
were come along Limpy that was mean I'm
sorry I'm not an ableist but you're
really so right now come on ah
so following mechanics is low aah Oh God
Oh hahaha okay here we go oh man this is
gonna take four
ever what happens if I go visit the guy
now she wouldn't be able to crawl under
the frame whatever oh so slow stop
looking like a ghost see goo coming
behind me
don't whisper such weird things while
we're wandering out of up the hill you
can see what looks like torchlight are
they about to start the ceremony yeah
you probably shouldn't go up there right
now what do you mean a price you can go
up there right now that's where I think
I need to go I'm going up there anyway
screw it
what no I want to go up there oh no
uh-uh
fine I won't go up scuse me
oh sorry when the wrong way again
whoopsies all right come on me oh I'm
just gonna leave you behind I don't need
to wait for you oh now oh now you're
skipped to your loo oh now you're going
hibbity whoo
how do we get to the old tree maybe the
other pathway no that doesn't lead to
anywhere
how do I get to the old tree I think
there was a way to get to the old tree
pretty sure no the way to get to the old
tree but they don't know that's the
Reaver oh the other path
was that another the fork in the road
yes there must have been it I went to
totally wrong way I did not need to go
over to our edge wasted a whole bunch of
time wandering in the darkness gray
waver bog good ol sis come along Limpy
come on oh we all know that injury
probably was fatal and probably killed
you and you're probably dead in ghosts
but hey we're gonna keep going come on
any minute now
sorry this is gonna take a while
everybody bear with it's gonna be worth
it in the end because it's definitely
not gonna be give a wrong way again I'm
definitely gonna be able to keep going
forever not embarrass myself any further
no way no how
and
as wrong
up here oh yeah I didn't I heard I saw
the words I didn't hear you actually say
anything I'm just assuming cuz that's
your your so far bad come on Meowth wait
oh go see who's it go see we've gotta go
see oh I see the ghosty okay so it's
garden the old tree huh ye oh no
ghosties oh okay a different place shows
in the foot oh that's the house up the
other way looks like an altar that's
just right up the way okay I know that
I've been there before
well I was wandering a million times
from Sunday okay come on come on come on
rah go go got it Hey Hey mio mio mio to
the rescue me oh hey scuse me or hear me
oh come on I'll push you up mio mio to
the rescue bo okay me also going up
mules going slower you was going quick
yeah me all-hearing meals go to the
stairs
Oh dad run oh yeah and there we go
me Oh Oh who's there who do who that who
that who that man at shrine who do you
think you is Manish Rhine I win for
nobody me always for no one maybe me
maybe all right what do we got mule
yo-yo it plays very mysterious mure ah
there we go that's the shrine that I
needed it looks like there's some other
items that have respawned down here
hello
Asha I got it I got it good I did it I
did like I won I won the money okay
twins go under a fence that's the fence
immediately to the right of here that
you can't even fake me and say that's
far away that's immediately to the right
of here ah ma ma ma ma okay got it I'm
on the way making my way downtown I
found a map of the acids way if you know
what I mean among the old books it seems
to be of an underground cave used for
the ritual it also looks like there
might be a way out of the village this
exit was also accessible from the shrine
grounds but that was sealed no guru
thanks mister folklorist sure of made
whoopee whoopee why William was iffy to
do da roca huh Jennifer Burnett
forever dick hey let's go Oh No oh that
wasn't fatal frame sorry I meant to
really hurt you I didn't mean to just
okey I meant to really wail on you you
want to show me show me your good side
come at me bro come at me bro what are
you doing
Oh where are you going pretty go Oh
where'd he go hey he's over there oh I
keep back here you dingus
uh this guy's this camera-shy hope there
you hey buddy
gotcha francha oh no where'd you go wait
whoa whoa whoa where'd you go
Oh where'd you go oh damn it you went
into the wall how am I supposed to be
able to get fatal frame shots if they
keep going into the walls what a bunch
of baloney how about I come out here so
I can fight him uneven ground
how about it brah she's just gonna go
after my you always go after my you why
you get away from the damn wall
damn it my you really okay thank you my
Oh for [ __ ] I don't want to take a
picture of you mind you I really don't
where'd you bury God come on there's a
guess good enough for me my you come
over here please me Oh
anybody yeah there is
come on show me your good side
oh I thought there might have been a
feels wrong well apparently not
uh-oh what won't face Petey Petey Petey
Petey gums office damn to the salad I
meant to do I meant to do much more
damaging than get back here you
ding-dong yeah I thought I was gonna get
the panel frame but that was good enough
for me
an old man who's a ghost in also dead
good job there buddy
great jab buckaroo okay so this is what
we knew before I've already been here I
don't know if I showed you guys but I've
been here before
okay so what's back here that we need to
know about wait was there a point to
this tell me there was a point to this
right there was a point to this wasn't
there okay fine
that this way was sealed up long ago I'm
assuming I only needed to kill that dude
or exercise that particular ghost so I
can go through the passageway now this
is what I'm guessing glowing yellow
crystal yeah more horror stories to tell
in the dark I love it I love it already
oh did I listen to this other floor you
and I did not
you keep that up you're gonna be no
alone yes for not so well
sighing you wrote no no no no thank you
methinks my you has a little bit of a
problem
colo write a real go night what is this
Elder Scrolls where you playing our go I
would believe that yep
Gregg oh yeah sure the shuttin shop yeah
so something went horribly wrong side
became possessed by a demon within the
shrine do everything up upgrade points I
don't know sometime oh I have a lot of
upgrade points I did good
how do I just upgrade the level because
this is a level 1 camera it says at the
top I don't know how to just upgrade the
levels that way yeah get more blasty
power oh I can upgrade that again yay
I'm gonna have super blast yay I got
super blast now all right I'm gonna be
even better at vanquishing these ghosts
so long as they stop being a-holes to me
how's this doll over here doing what
doll doing good good ok nevermind I'm
assuming that I did what I needed to do
and now I'm gonna be able to go over
there to the tree and crawl under and be
able to get out of here or so I think
it's not really the end of the game is
it not even close not by a long shot
not by Lang shat NEBOSH long shot not by
a blonde blot
John I don't want to you dingus Barry
you're more than one of you it sounds
like there might be more than one aim
hey how's it going it's good picture of
you how you doing
I don't want to accept my destiny you
accept your destiny of dying like an
a-hole don't stand so close to me buy
you a seal whoa whoa whoa come on give
me something good oh well that wasn't
what I was wanting to do but good enough
for me oh I am so tell
oh he's dingleberries okay give me some
good
yeah I gotcha okay you're done you're
done yeah he went too far away
god dammit how was Adam without getting
those commas it's really annoying you
wanna mess with me oh me oh it's gonna
get them your super powers unlike you've
ever known hit me dammit I keep thinking
that that sex is his attack I mean I was
just gonna dance while waiting for you
you Oh meow meow meow meow
mio mio oh there oh oh I thought I was
gonna get there I thought I was gonna be
right on time with that ah damn it
I was meowing too hard ma'am gotcha
oh god damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn dammit
dammit dammit mio mio excuse me excuse
me my office giving good
show me good Danna tell isn't good oh
he's got so much health why knees here
so much hell anything gonna do some come
to some no oh yes you are
yeah okay here we go alright
feels good one I can actually accomplish
something I don't even think I needed to
kill that guy
Rogers a waste of my time oh I'll just
me all up to where I was before I'll
just carry on stupid precinct they can
stop me okay here we go into the cave
hopefully there's a safe point in there
cutscene
oh my you oh you're there okay good why
did you need to run away I killed the
priest where i exorcise the priest
hello pinwheels my you know
let me rest while you are you okay sorry
that didn't have any subtitle Stuart my
you are you alright you don't know that
okay pinwheel stone tablet is inserted
in the shrine a device for opening the
passage there are four other places
around it for inserting similar stone
tablets okay some kind of light octagon
key oh no not at her that alright
there's probably gonna give me a clue as
to where I can find the rest of the
pieces something shows in the photo yes
I know
maybe it's missing part of the
mechanical for the mechanical dolls yeah
I understand because I've already gotten
a piece or I already have a piece guy I
detect a blue glue oh oh there we go
fallen my you why do I detect her
ghostly spirits why do I need to take
pictures of her why am I wasting my type
fourteen film there we go
something shows in the photo of my you
okay a woman crying in front of the
building it looks like the storehouse
okay so I need to go back to the
storehouse is that what you say alright
hmm okay thank you for the clue there
that's really helpful I'm so glad that
we had this talk twins play an important
part in the ritual in recent years the
government issued a decree that the
first twin to come out is the eldest
each region used to have its own rules
until that decree would made but I asked
the ceremony master about the religious
rules he green and said that tradition
is tradition this village still
practices the old way the twin that is
born second has considered the elder for
some stupid reason or whatever I don't
know why that point was important but
there we go alright so either way yes
get out of here I need to go back to the
storehouse but before I do that I'm
actually all out of time for this
episode so as soon as I find the same
point I'm done
I'm out of here I can rest with all of
my accomplishments in hand wait this is
a different area what is this
wait there's a totally different area
where the hell am I now I see some over
there can't tell me I don't this see
some right there there's some it's all
awesome I want it I'm only bad or maybe
I'll just get it when I go farther up
the path probably okay we're not where
the hell am i oh I am in the cemetery
oh oh I made a big loop oh I'm a
loop-de-loop
okay so there's a loop-de-loop area at
the back to the beginning of the where
it was before ah that is cool that is
kooky that is crazy that is awesome
so now that I know that I know that
there's another safe point up in this
staging area up here I could just get to
there I didn't know I was so far away
hey look a shrine maiden' thing do you
have any goodies behind you apparently
not okay good thing I didn't need to
find out one way in the beginning of the
game are also I never would have been
able to do this
who would have all been lost to me
forever and ever and ever and ever I
already did that one so the save point
is right over right over I know there's
a save point here I know there is I know
that I know there's a save point here is
there is a point there is a save point
there I know oh there it is okay up
there I was like right next to I didn't
even see it
okay so I just need to go wait I walked
right by that how did I not see that if
I just in here apparently
I brought you in that's a question okay
so I definitely saving a new one here
that's good okay let me just double save
double save I don't care
Yolo I don't care I'll double save it's
alright to me
got it Wow triple saved just to be sure
I don't want to make I don't wanna make
unsure I'm gonna have to go through all
that again okay we got that alright so
thank you all so much for watching we
made a lot of progress in this episode
and I did good you can't deny now I'm
getting better at the game hahaha it's
almost as if I didn't know how to play
when I didn't know how to play the game
in the beginning when I didn't know
anything about the game and now I know
about it because there's a learning
experience as you go through the game
there's a learning curve and I keep
pressing because I know and I haven't
made the game for I'm never played and
people who criticize me are wrong
because I tried so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in that video for you oh my
god
okay